it stands I know what it stands for gay
best friend my future GPS is just
waiting to come out of the closet tell
me how Barris is welcome to your weekly
ticket its Pride Month and we're
celebrating with our partners at Rotten
Tomatoes who have curated a list of 200
lgbtqia+ films and to help us sort
through that all-encompassing list we've
invited Michael váradi who's hosted the
queer fear panel for queer horror at
Comic Con for seven years
to choose four of his personal
highlights from that list I'm really
excited to be here thanks for having me
Kayla yeah what do you got for us
well you know in considering LGBTQ
cinema there has been sort of a uptick
in recent years of movies that the
public's aware and aware of like love
sign and moonlight won Best Picture we
have movies like call me by your name or
the trouble with Harry that just was on
free form this year so there is a little
more visibility with with LGBTQ cinema
but we have a rich history of films that
I think the general public especially
during Pride Month would do well to
discover and so the movies I picked
today are sort of a swath of different
experiences in the first movie I wanted
to talk about is a movie called Paris is
burning it's a documentary from 1990
directed by filmmaker named Jenny
Livingston and for fans of RuPaul's Drag
Race this is the this is sort of the
foundations Paris is burning as a
documentary all about black and Latin
extract Queens and trans performers in
New York City in the late 80s early 90s
who were part of the ball culture and
for those of you who don't know what
that is that's where voguing comes from
it's sort of if you watch pose on FX
that that history runs simultaneous to
to the events of Paris is burning Paris
is burning is a documentary about the
true lives of these people and a lot of
the terminology that we see RuPaul use
on drag race that has now been adopted
in popular culture like throwing shade
or reading somebody we were first taught
that generally speaking as audience
members by Paris's burning because the
movie literally when it was made
obviously drag queens were not seen
frequently on television or in pop
culture's so when you're in the
of the film they have one drag performer
Dorian quarry where she sits and
actually explains to the audience when I
say throwing shade it means this and
they like put the term up on that like
like a documentary
you know the style where they put the
term up they give a definition so the
folks at home can be like highest or in
shape but it's it's a really really
remarkable document not just of kind of
the culture and the terminology but
really shows how the drag landscape was
was shaped by black and Latin X voices
as well as you know a lot of modern pop
culture things yeah you know Madonna was
inspired by that moment that's where the
song vogue comes from Ryan Murphy makes
Poe's about this time and all of the
things that that we see in Paris is
burning which in the documentary are
happening in real time have become very
foundational to queer culture so it's
like if you and Pride Month want to get
your education this is a great place to
start well that's that's a that's really
interesting I didn't realize that that
like the RuPaul drag race thing went so
far back that's as far as inspiration
that's crazy great awesome
what else you got if you loved love
Simon if you like a good rom-com teen
comedy because who doesn't we all grew
up with them one of my favorite gay
movies is a film called GBF which is an
acronym for gay best friend it was made
in 2013 and by filmmaker Darren Stein
who most fans know as the writer and
director of jawbreaker Darren made this
movie it was written by George Northey
and directed by Darren Stein and it is
about it's about a teen who accidentally
gets outed as gay in high school and the
the cliques of popular girls who fight
over him because they have realized the
most important accessory that they could
possibly have to prove their queendom of
the school is a gay best friend
and sort of his journey about you know
trying to be friends with the head of
the theater club where the head
cheerleader or you know the the etre
girl and then sort of discovering I'm
not an accessory I'm a person and it's a
really heartfelt film it's funny and I
think
it's it's a really great teen comedy for
a generation of come up incoming kids
because when I was young I didn't really
have gay teen comedy it's like I would
have killed to have a movie like this
when I was growing up so it's really
nice to know that the new generation has
these movies that they can look to and
see a bit of themselves in and it's
really it's it's a little naughty a
little a little sarcastic and a whole
lot of fun are you describing yourself
yeah that's me what else you got it kind
of in a similar vein another movie I
wanted to recommend is a movie called
but I'm a cheerleader from 1999 it was
directed by a filmmaker named Jamie
Babbitt for people who are familiar with
the teen movies of the 90s like scream
or you know 10 Things I Hate About You
it was a big moment to have ensemble
casts so you have like everybody who is
popular on the CW or the WB at the time
right and you put them in these movies
and those were the movies we latched on
to and but I'm a cheerleader is is sort
of the queer answer to that it's got
this power 90s cast natasha Lyonne Clea
Duvall RuPaul's in it Cathy Moriarty is
an amazing amazing group of people uh
and natasha Lyonne plays a high school
cheerleader whose parents suspect that
maybe something's a little different
about her because she listens to Melissa
Etheridge and likes to hug her friends a
little too long so they sent her to a
conversion therapy camp essentially
where she ends up meeting a girl who
makes her realize her truest self so I
mean there's the various a very serious
issue of conversion therapy is baked
into this teen comedy but then much like
GBF helps you know that journey of
finding who you really are and that's
important but I'm a cheerleader does
that as well and it doesn't in that
delicious hyper colored nighties way and
and it's just a lot of fun
RuPaul's in it as one of the camp
counselors John Waters fans would
recognize mink stole plays Natasha's mom
it's just a really really fun in good
movie and it's one of my favorite
lesbian romance films so highly
recommend it yeah I'm excited to jump
into this one too I saw the the trailer
and it's so like beautifully stylized
it's very vibrant yeah and it was
definitely a film of that time because
when you watch those movies of the 90s
they all had that kind of frenetic
energy and I sort of missed that yeah I
think that you know pride when you look
at the various pride flags including the
the classic rainbow flag and and you
know all the different flags that
followed it's all very colorful so to
have a movie like but I'm a cheerleader
that like leans into the hyper colors
there's like an awareness of it it's
like you know pride is about living
bright and living out loud and here's a
movie that is bright and out loud and
it's a lot of fun so it feels like a
perfect movie for this month awesome
awesome
and then probably the heaviest movie on
my list but I think is very important is
a movie called a fantastic woman it's
from 2017 and it was directed by
Sebastian lilo and it is on my list
because in the landscape of queer cinema
in terms of mainstream representation we
still are lacking greatly in trans
narratives and this movie is a very
important trans narrative it was it's
about a woman who works as a waitress
and then moonlights as a nightclub
singer and she meets somebody who and
she falls in love and when that person
dies how her that guy's family denies
her access to her own grieving and and
her and the prejudices she deals with
because of who she is and it is a
harrowing journey that I think ends in a
little bit of personal triumph but it's
all it's it's a really really great
movie it was its from Chile and it was
submitted as a contender for Best
Foreign Language Film to the Academy
Awards and it won in 2018 so it's it's a
really exemplary example of queer cinema
and if you're looking for something that
really really has a powerful message
this is a good film there is a great
tradition of LGBTQ films you know and
this is really just a primer for movies
to kind of kick start your month but I
encourage people to dig deeper if you
like this there's so many many
other great queer films out there from a
wide variety of filmmakers you know if
you love drag queens watch Vegas in
space watch Priscilla Queen of the
desert if you like something a little
outrageous dig up the cinema of John
Waters you know if you like teen
comedies there are there are many edge
of seventeen get real I think that just
like our community there are so many
different ways to express yourself in so
many different identities there is a
movie for you out there and if you don't
feel the movie is out there go make it
because we need it so Michael Variety
I'm so happy I had you on I'm absolutely
gonna watch all of these I'm really
excited about it
and if you'd like more recommendations
our friends over at Rotten Tomatoes have
compiled a list of the best LGBTQIA
films of all time most of which are
available on Fandango now so check that
out and if we missed one leave us a
comment and let us know why it's your
favorite I'm Cale anonymous and I'll
catch you next time
[Music]